it doesn't look small like that looks
like a half a real water like normal
watermelon hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen so today's
what I in a date youtuber review is of
Gabi Hannah so she is a youtuber a
singer-songwriter and an author and a
lot of you guys have asked me to review
her diet so for those of you who have
followed Gabi you may know she's kind of
being on a bit of a fitness journey
she's trying to improve her overall
health and get into shape and this
particular video is about a year old so
I know not ideal but a lot of you who
have asked me specifically about this
this video because she details what she
did to lose weight and it's also like
the most recent lomi that we have
so without adieu let's do this not
exactly my usual definition of late
night drunk eats but good job Gabi
loud and clear I am NOT a dietitian this
is what works for me I'm not telling you
this is the right way or this is the
only way this is just what after years
and years of weight loss battles and
different trainers and nutritionists and
dietitians and a lot of conflicting
advice from different people and the
internet they part said if you want to
take tips take the advice as far as the
actual foods that I'm eating take with a
grain of salt also because this is the
internet and there is a comment section
and everybody's entitled to their
opinion obviously you're free to leave
whatever critiques or opinions you have
about my diet in my lifestyle below but
I've tried many many things for many
many years and I'm finally so happy and
genuinely say I feel and look amazing
and this is what works so right off the
top I want to say thank you Gabi for
that disclaimer it's really rare and
refreshing that a youtuber will come out
and say hey this is kind of what worked
for me but it's not necessarily gonna
work for you she's calling out that
she's not a registered dietician or a
health care provider but that she's just
kind of like gone on this journey and
this is what she's learned
has felt good for her body so thank you
Gabby for that you and what makes you
and your body look and feel incredible I
think that the most frustrating and
honestly sometimes heartbreaking thing
when it comes to weight loss is all of
the conflicting advice and opinions out
there everybody has an opinion some
people will tell you to eat only three
big meals a day some people will tell
you to eat six small meals a day some
people will say don't eat certain foods
other people say that exact same food is
essential to your diet if you are not
one of the beautiful unicorns who is
blessed with a mythical genetic makeup
figuring it out can be really really
difficult but you have to not give up
you have to not let the missteps or the
backslide stop you you can't just let
one bad week make you give up entirely
give yourself and your body a lot of
time to figure out what makes it happy
it took me at least six or seven months
to figure it out you know on top of 15
years it was not easy I cried a lot I
made a lot of changes a lot of times and
I'm sure I'm going to have to continue
to change things as my body changes my
workout plan changes my cravings change
I hope that's one thing that you do take
away from this even just from this intro
is give yourself time make as many
changes as you need to and you'll get
there okay so what I'm going to show you
is so totally agree with Gabby on the
fact that like yeah like the
all-or-nothing mentality is not healthy
and you need to really tune in to your
body's intuition to find out what feels
good to you but I just kind of wanted a
flag the kind of fits po diet culture
language that what's going on there just
because I do feel like that could be
triggering for some people and I don't
want people to to hear that and feel
like a little bit of victim blaming like
oh if I'm not feeling great or if I'm
not at the weight that I want to be that
I'm just not trying hard enough and I
and I've given up so I just want to flag
that that may be problematic I also
agree with Gabby how she said that like
you know my diet has changed so many
times and it's probably gonna have to
change again as my cravings change and
my needs change and my work has changed
yeah that's true and that's why relying
on kind of
like meal plans or diet plans that we
read about online doesn't make sense
because it's just not intuitive it's not
about listening to your body's true
needs in that moment on that day which
ultimately are going to change based on
so many different factors so yeah try to
listen to your body rather than just
relying on these external cues stay
tuned to the end for my tips on eating
to lose weight how to stay fool how to
kick craving it's always give myself two
hours before I workout or training so I
eat I wait two hours and then I train it
gives your body time to burn up the
actual food so that when you actually go
to workout your body is not burning body
fat okay so let's talk for a hot minute
about fasted cardio so yes technically
there are some mild benefits associated
with fasted cardio which is kind of what
she's just talking about how like you
know if you get up in the morning and
you don't eat and you do your cardio
then your body will see a slight
increase in the fat burning potential
however we also know that you know
depending on the length of your workout
it also increases the risk of you
burning into your protein stores aka
your muscle as well so if you're working
out at higher intensities or strength
training then fasting before workout is
not really necessarily the best idea in
fact most authorities and sports
nutrition recommend somewhere between 1
to 4 grams of carbohydrates per kilogram
of body weight as a pre-workout snack
for any workouts that are lasting longer
than an hour also choosing a pre-workout
meal or snack that is lower in fiber
lower in fat and also sometimes lower in
protein depending on your activity may
also help you out with your activity
because a lot of these foods tend to sit
a little bit heavier and they may cause
gastrointestinal distress if you're kind
of doing a really kind of high-intensity
workout so I love Gabby's message about
getting some fuel in the tank before a
workout but whether or not you need to
be so strict and deliberate about it for
fat burning potential is pretty much up
for debate find that especially
I'm trying to slim down and this is also
my hangover breakfast it is bacon now
this is nitrate-free bacon I have no
idea how important that is figure the
person who told me about it was my
psycho nutritionist who doesn't know
anything but I'm like okay so psycho
nutritionist aside not gonna really
comment on that but the whole kind of
natural or nitrate-free bacon thing is
kind of a marketing scheme so nitrates
or nitrites are preservatives that are
responsible for the color and flavor in
cured needs and research suggests that
they may be carcinogenic when consumed
in large amounts so nitrates actually
are found naturally in foods like celery
leafy greens root vegetables drinking
water baked goods things like that and
the nitrates in celery are often
actually used to make natural nitrate
salts for curing meat sounds great to go
natural which I guess is why your psycho
nutritionist was recommending it however
your body doesn't really differentiate
between sources so at this point it's
really unclear whether or not the risks
of consuming nitrate free bacon are
really any different listen I have no
problem with bacon in moderation
however it is a highly processed
high-fat high-salt product and synthetic
nitrates or not probably it's not a
great everyday option also there is
potential that cooking a lot of these
ultra processed foods on high heat Slyke
you would do if your pan frying may
increase cancer-causing compounds like
heterocyclic amines and polycyclic
aromatic hydrocarbons it's a mouthful
started eating my treat free bacon since
then because it sounded like it was
healthier to eat that two eggs half of
an avocado
okay alright let's make some breakfast
combinations of food are super super
important for example a lot of people
give me crap about eating bacon but I
actually thought I want to eat bacon
consistently you guys slim down really
quickly and a lot of trainers actually
recommend bacon what I will not touch
it's turkey bacon any meat or anything
that is processed to look like another
piece that just means chemical form
nothing that is chemically engineered to
look or taste like a thing that it is
not making is full of fat but that is
good your body needs fat especially if
you're eating pretty low fat the rest of
the day when bacon is bad weather is
when you eat it with the wrong foods so
for example if I ate it on toast every
morning that would be a bad food
combination I want oh so much to cover
okay let's clear this one up first of
all in the turkey bacon yeah like turkey
bacon is a highly processed food it
probably shouldn't have the health halo
that that like marketing departments
have granted it
however pork bacon is also a highly
processed food so whichever one you
choose just enjoy it in moderation yes I
would say that in a lot of cases turkey
bacon has a little bit more sodium and
salt then pork bacon does but both are
really high salt options so just kind of
go easy whichever way you go as for the
food combining like haven't we talked
about this
maybe Gabby can like get a refresh on my
video right here but here's the cold
notes there's very little research to
suggest that there's any benefits to
kind of these food combinations whether
it's like don't combine fats with
protein or whatever the they are but the
reality is your body is a [ __ ] rock
star and it can multitask
to break down and digest a variety of
foods at the same time without causing
digestive distress and inflammation
leaving it there
and it's burnt I use the same bacon
grease to cook my eggs in fat and that's
my alarm clock
follow me on snapchat know that this is
in fact not for noon and evening I love
her singing ah yeah I also hate when the
fire alarm goes off but I don't know
maybe for Gabby that's like a good
reminder to like turn down the heat
because cooking those animal fats on a
really high heat like we talked about
before it can increase those PAH and HCA
carcinogens somebody told me that that
makes them stay fresher and I blindly
believe things that sound like they make
sense
probably so kind of make sense I guess
but like not the best way to preserve
your avocado it's kind of a myth it may
just like prevent that like little pit
area from browning but avec I was just
Brown really [ __ ] fast so if you
really want to keep them fresher longer
and prevent them from going brown put
plastic wrap right on the surface or you
can use those kind of cute little
reusable avocado containers that I've
seen online I think those work as well
pretty good but yeah some I said just
brown okay like a weirdo honestly a lot
of it will fill you it gives me a lot of
energy like I don't get hungry for five
six hours and that's after an intense
two hour workout and so uh yeah like
that looks like a pretty filling meal I
feel like I would be barely satiated um
I like that there's a good variety there
it doesn't seem like she's like
explicitly kind of restricting any kind
of food groups necessarily so that's
great but there is a lot of fat there
there's a lot of proteins so yes very
filling definitely would keep me full
for a fairly long time but I would
probably wreck
cutting back on the processed meats
probably wouldn't be necessary totally
fine it's a weekend treat but I wouldn't
recommend like eating bacon every single
day as like your go-to breakfast so
maybe having some like whole grains in
there like some whole grain toast would
be a great way to kind of swap in for
the process bacon and you don't need to
worry about the whole food combining
thing the whole grains with the fat
totally [ __ ] we've already covered that
but I just think would be a better
choice as a pre-workout snack to give
her that energy that she needs to get
through the workout I'm gonna just like
excuse this as the fact that like she
has come out and said that this is like
her hangover breakfast totally fair girl
I get you but if we're talking about
like pre-workout fuel I think carbs
would probably do her a lot better than
like a heavy kind of greasy meal like
this which would probably fit in my gut
and make me not want to workout calories
are not everything but they are
important no matter what you might hear
this is my school thought you can
believe whatever you want my school
thought is energy and energy out that's
how you burn fat now you may watch me
eat while I watch youtube videos uh yes
the whole calories in calories out move
more eat less that's the diet culture
promise but what she's missing out on
here is the whole sustainability piece
can you do this diet for the rest of
your life if no then it's probably not
worth embarking on in the first place
it's just far too restrictive to be a
healthy sustainable lifestyle the
research shows us that diets weight loss
diets don't work they don't work because
they're not intuitive and they forced us
to ignore our body's innate wisdom and
in fact not only do 95% of diets fail
and people gain that weight right back
but because of the metabolic changes
that are associated with restriction and
the hormone changes often times we
actually gain that weight plus more back
homey gain that weight so is it worth it
I would say no
if you can track your calories for at
least a little while I didn't in the
beginning because where I was mentally
it didn't feel like the healthiest thing
to do obviously if you have negative
feelings about calories and eating in
general that is something that you need
to seek professional help for
immediately I highly highly urge you to
but once I got that all out of my head
this is probably the single most
important part of my weight-loss journey
first of all I learned that I wasn't
eating even close to the amount of food
that I should have been eating but I
didn't know that because I wasn't
counting when I started eating a lot
more I started losing a lot more get
this guy's your body needs food to live
if you aren't eating enough your body is
going to cling on to the weight your
cortisol levels are gonna go up on that
note you have to be honest with yourself
when you really hold yourself
accountable and you truly start entering
in everything that you're eating you're
less likely to eat something that is bad
for you or mmm okay um so one thing that
really surprised me that is that Gabi
seems to believe that she was able to
kind of like turn off those disorderly
thoughts and get over it and start to
count calories healthfully again which
is honestly not really a thing that I'm
aware of that
you know chronic dieters are capable of
in fact just based on some of the the
language that I'm hearing Gabi use I
don't think that she's kind of fully
over her disorderly tendencies at all I
also think it's incredibly backwards to
assume that we need some kind of like
tracker or app to tell us to eat enough
food our body is incredibly smart and if
we're listening it will guide us to eat
the right amount of food this is kind of
like this is like diet culture talking
at the moment this is this is somebody
who's who's talking about her experience
not being able to listen to her body
ultimately as a result of being so
engrossed in diet culture for so long
it's very hard to turn that off and it's
not something that's just gonna happen
you know on the fly but you would be
amazed how incredibly stable people's
weights are when they are eating
intuitively your body is ash
able to make small adjustments for days
that you know you maybe eat a little bit
more or eat a little bit less so we do
not I repeat we do not need an app to
tell us what to eat not for a short
amount of time not ever so one thing I
do agree with gabion is that your body
needs food to live and a lot of the
times people find that when they stop
restricting their body goes and finds
the healthiest happiest weight that it's
meant to be it just kind of regulates
itself in its metabolism resets so
that's not necessarily untrue a you know
like a lot of the times people find that
when they actually start eating more or
more regularly they actually kind of
lose weight just because that's the way
that their body wants to be however you
can gain all of this knowledge from you
from your unique body you don't need an
app to tell you any of this but the most
most most important thing to remember
when talking about calories please read
my lips is they are very important but
they are not everything there are some
healthy foods that have way more
calories than unhealthy foods but it's
much better to put that thing in your
mouth with more calories the best way
I've ever heard this explain to me
imagine having a 100 calorie pack of
banana muffins and an actual banana the
100 calorie pack of muffins has you
guessed it 100 calories the banana has
110 calories so a lot of people if they
get too obsessed at the idea of counting
calories would go for the 100 calorie
pack of muffins
however the muffins are full of
processed food and garbage and the
banana is a whole food packed with
nutrients but it's very good for your
body cap okay so I just want a flag that
we don't necessarily need to be calling
foods like garbage or junk or toxic or
whatever food is food and let's just
kind of like leave it at that but one
thing for sure is that it's not just
about
korone micronutrients it's also about
satiety here and some foods that are
higher in protein and fiber and fat
maybe higher in calories than other
options but they're also gonna keep you
satisfied longer so you're less likely
to overeat later on in the day it's also
about emotional satisfaction so yeah
there's definitely a lot of moving parts
here when it comes to how to eat but
bottom line I think we can all agree at
this point calorie counting
times a day as often as I can this is
not for debate this is what my trainer
recommended to me and I was very very
resistant to it mainly because I was
afraid that I was going to be hungry all
day and because I know I have an
emotional attachment to eating so
someone telling me I have to eat half as
many times as I want to be eating it's
really really hard however when I
started following this rule that's when
the weight really started coming off the
spiking my insulin half the amount of
time that normally was through the day
science google it and I was forcing
myself to eat more calories so that I
wouldn't get hungry again lots of good
calories less times in the day for me
that was the trick I also wait five or
more hours in between each meal before I
eat again because that's how long it
takes for your body to actually use up
the food and then get into the burn zone
science Google it again I'm not a
dietitian this is what my trainer who
has transformed so many people's lives
and bodies told me to do and when I
started falling it
okay so there's two things here that
Gabi points out one is that she only
eats three times a day and two is that
she spaces those meals out by five hours
each time the media has really
flip-flopped back and forth between
recommending eating three meals a day or
like one big meal a day and then eating
these small like kind of frequent meals
throughout the day and whether or not
one is better than the other I mean we
don't really know the science has not
been conclusive probably because it's
really highly an individual thing based
on each of our metabolism the science
that Gabi is talking about science
Google it's the fact that insulin gets
released when we consume any foods that
contain carbohydrate and insulin is
actually a growth hormone in fact when
people who have diabetes are instructed
to take insulin injections as part of
our medications help manage their blood
Sugar's it's sometimes can cause weight
gain and this is simply because insulin
helps you absorb and store sugar as for
this 5-hour rule this is probably based
on the suggestion that your liver around
the five hour mark starts to produce its
own sugar and release it into blood when
we haven't had any food and this is why
we actually usually suggest that people
try to have Sling to eat every four to
five hours because that's actually when
we start to see our blood Sugar's rise
however it's not really accurate to
suggest that your body will kind of go
into fat-burning mode at the five hour
mark most of us have kind of stored up
glucose stores we call it glycogen that
our body uses and mobilizes in times of
fasting and it would much rather pull
from those and have that glucose ready
than to start to burn through muscle or
fat which is just less efficient as fuel
to actually get to that stage where
you're starting to burn fat because your
glycogen stores are depleted would
probably take you between 24 hours and
two days of not consuming any
carbohydrates so when it comes down to
this debate about how much to eat and
when to eat it really is an individual
thing what we need to do is learn how to
tune into our body and eat when we're
hungry and stop when we're full
that is a much better predictor of
weight regulation than any of these
arbitrary rules time to eat again I had
a really good workout so when I get home
I'm just hungry and ready to eat my
favorite favorite favorite thing to do
is eat some type of fruit while I'm
waiting for anything else to heat up
because it's like candy to me at this
point like the same with a grapefruit
this is my favorite when I'm done
working out 1/2 of a personal watermelon
it's so juicy I'm salivating thinking
about it it's so sweet it makes my mouth
feel it all all hydrated and just
explode I love the watermelon so much
it's my favorite fruit and it just
hydrates you and replenishes you from
your workout plan your meals and prep ok
so I love watermelon and I agree so
hydrating so sweet so delicious also I
don't know what a personal watermelon
this is kind of never heard that term
before but ok but yeah if she's really
interested in hydration post-workout
water is also a great choice very
important and more hydrating than really
any kind of food pure h2o and I would
really love to see her incorporate you
know some protein after the workout in
fact I would love to actually see these
meals swapped even so that she was
having more carbohydrates more
energizing carbs before the workout and
then those protein that protein to
replenish and refuel those muscles so
that would be my recommendation it's
also like a lot of watermelon and so
yeah just a little bit more balance
would be ideal plan your meals and prep
I literally scheduled my day around make
sure I'm awake in time to eat two hours
before I train I make sure I can eat
pretty much right after I train I'm
going after the night I make sure I have
a big dinner first I only thought cooked
food in my fridge ready to go like
chicken boiled eggs but I could just
grab and eat always have a ton of fresh
fruit laying around love melons love
pears love peaches you have the things
you're supposed to be eating readily
available
okay so agree that meal prep and
planning is Sookie I'm all about being
prepared but planning your date around
eating and what to eat
sounds disorderly to me and and and
really problematic so yeah
planning and prepping if healthy and
great I mean nobody wants to be
frantically trying to put together a
meal at 6:00 p.m. but obsessing over it
and planning your entire day around food
sounds disorderly not healthy that's so
extreme and I know that Gabby has said
that she has overcome her kind of
disorderly tendencies but that sounds
disorderly to me people who have a
healthy relationship with food don't
need to purge their home of sugar and
get rid of any kind of sugar that
surrounds them that's just not realistic
because people who have a healthy
relationship with food don't obsess and
pine over it I can honestly say that I
have a freezer full of cookies and ice
cream and a pantry stuffed with
chocolate and I rarely rarely think
about it I'm not crazy hungry I'm gonna
stick with four ounces we're just about
that much frozen vegetables this is a
lifesaver for me you just pop it in the
microwave frozen vegetables fun fact
I've learned are actually apparently you
feel free debate me on it obviously I'm
not a scientist but are apparently
better for you than fresh vegetables
because fresh vegetables when they're
spitting out the nutrients are
constantly dying as they're sitting on
the shelf
whereas with frozen vegetables they
usually flash freeze them pretty much as
soon as they're picked so all the
nutrients are frozen and then when you
cut them they're I don't know but for me
they're more convenient easier to cook
find help yeah I'm not gonna debate you
on that Gabby because I agree I think
that frozen vegetables are like highly
underrated but the way that our food
system works today is that a lot of our
food at least you know where I love here
in Canada
is transported very long distances and
the nutrients are degrading over time in
transportation whereas like you said
those frozen vegetables they're
flash-frozen the nutrients are locked in
and they're just more convenient and in
a lot of cases depending on the season
can also be cheaper as well so yeah I
love frozen vegetables I've got up a
freezer packed with frozen vegetables
and fruit and ice cream yeah balanced
folks all in moderation fresh fruit on
that no try to cut up as much unnatural
processed carbs and sugar as humanly
possible believe me on this again theme
of the video it takes time but your
taste buds will change okay so like it
looks like a pretty simple basic
relatively balanced meal I mean she said
that she had a sweet potato but it's not
shown so I guess she ate the sweet
potato at some point and half of a
personal watermelon um so yeah she's got
some kind of slow digesting carbs she's
got some vegetables quite a lot of good
vegetables they're green beans she's got
4 ounces of chicken breasts as she is
measured out don't love that but still
I'm just happy to see that it's like a
little bit more balanced and it's a
lower fat meal than what she had at
breakfast so that really does point to
the fact why it's really important that
we're not just kind of like looking at
each meal or snack in isolation because
balanced over time this lower fat meal
is gonna balance out the higher fat meal
that she had earlier on in the day so
yeah I'm happy it's simple it's kind of
very easy to assemble and look
successful in terms of how to put it
together so that's great as for Gabby's
suggestion on kind of cutting back on
soda totally love that
I love sparkling water myself and it is
really a great way to kind of help
retrain your taste buds to appreciate
just naturally hydrating foods that do
not have all this added sugar in them
you can have so much fun my plays are
boring it's because I'm boring a buck
and also I'm lazy but I like these
things these are the things that taste
good to me but look at Brad the peas I
know you can make buffalo wings out of
cauliflower and a lot of people make
cauliflower crust pizza make fun chips
dip that of things at one but I'm Way
too lazy I'm gonna time for that I love
putting garlic salts on vegetables
it makes them taste so much younger now
tracking what you eat is it so at least
like Gabi's honest with herself yeah
like I I'm happy that from what I see
her meal at least for dinner meal here
looks pretty balanced I'm seeing you
know carbs I'm seeing lots of vegetables
I'm seeing some kind of lean protein so
that's great having said that it is
pretty repetitive and I feel like for
people who enjoy variety and kind of
trying different recipes and unique
flavors this might be really boring and
not sustainable and feel super
restrictive but the most important thing
is like it seems to be satisfying to
Gabby and like she said she's just like
too busy you know not really interested
in switching things up and making
elaborate recipes and that is totally
fair if it feels satisfying to Gabby
then that's what's important the
realization that this part isn't forever
in the beginning you do have to be a lot
stricter with yourself if your friends
are going out drinking two times a week
you can't I mean you can but it's going
to take you a lot longer to lose weight
if you really really love sleep and junk
food you have to cut it out you'll have
to skip the pizza in the desert for a
little while but not forever
there were so many times in the middle
of this journey I almost gave up forever
because I kept thinking I can't do this
for
the rest of my life cutting out things
that I want and not enjoying going out
with my friends and then I realized this
is the hard part once I change my body
and turn them into a machine that knows
how to handle food and burn fat your
body becomes a lot more forgiving and it
becomes maintenance get your body where
you oh I don't like that kind of talk
okay so basically what I have to say
about this is that yeah like being more
intense and strict with your diet is
going to lead to faster weight loss but
it also increases the risk of relapse
and weight cycling which evidence
suggests is actually more detrimental to
your health a lot more can be said for
the idea of actually learning how to
listen to your body and let it find its
healthiest happiest weight so there is
no such thing as just one narrow
definition of what healthy food is okay
so let's talk about Gabby's nutrition
for the day so according to my
calculations gabby is eating about
thirteen hundred and sixty nine calories
with 24 percent of her calories coming
from protein 41 percent from carbs and
35 percent from fat
okay so Gabby is heavily consuming fewer
calories than I think anyone else that
we've reviewed here but considering that
this is a weight loss diet video it
makes sense I guess this was meant to be
kind of like a caloric deficit for her
as for balance I would say that this is
like pretty well-balanced I mean her
carb percentage is a little bit lower
than what's recommended and her that's a
little bit higher but totally what's
within reason in my opinion especially
based on what kind of is in vogue right
now and and it seems like it's working
for her in her body
as for micronutrients I would say it's
unlikely that she's really missing out
on anything major because she's getting
a lot of fruits and vegetables and with
the exception of dairy I think basically
all of the food groups are represented
so that's great so here is what I like
about Gabby's diet number one
nothing is necessarily cut out she
doesn't explicitly talk about cutting
out specific foods or food groups even
though she is kind of like buying it to
the food combining thing which is
totally BS and I
no she eats dairy but again like not a
huge deal there are other sources of
calcium and vitamin D that you can get
that so I appreciate that
number two she focuses a lot on water
and hydration so this is great she talks
a lot about getting her hydration in she
makes it a priority so I definitely
think that's amazing
number three I would say her meals are
very accessible and easy basically
everything I saw was more assembly style
it didn't require any kind of outrageous
skill in the kitchen
all of the ingredients were easy to find
easy to access and really ultimately
easy to put together yeah she could
probably you know do with a little bit
more variety and creativity in her life
but if this works for her then that's
awesome okay so let's talk about what I
don't love about Gabby's diet first of
all it is based on some faulty science
so I really appreciate that Gabby has
come out and said hey I'm not a
nutrition expert I'm not a dietitian
this is just what works for me and feels
good to my body awesome however I don't
really agree and the science doesn't
agree with everything that Gabby has
come out and said and I think that she's
giving some kind of misinformation
tidbits that may be misleading for
people so at the end of January
Gabby actually posted a diet update
where she talked about how over
Thanksgiving and the holidays she had
put on some weight and then tried to go
on another fitness journey to transform
her body again in just a month now this
isn't to shame Gabby here I mean in fact
this is what I would expect from a
weight loss diet like this people
relapse people don't maintain that
weight loss it's just not sustainable
and it's just not realistic to transform
your body in a month it really just goes
to show that there are so many factors
that impact our weight and I'd much
rather see us focus on health and
well-being rather than the number on the
scale and finally I don't like her diet
culture rhetoric oh I really struggle
when I hear people talk about how
they're free from disordered eating and
yet they talk about food in such
dichotomous and moral terms saying
things like get rid of the junk in your
life
and your life will change seems
overwhelmingly extreme and obsessive and
not a healthy way to think about or talk
about food okay so bottom line I think
Gabi gave us a lot of suggestions here
that may be helpful and able to be
generalized to a lot of people however
what I learned in this video is that if
this is what it takes to lose weight and
not even to keep it off as her update
has suggested to us I don't see how it's
worth the sacrifice food should not be a
burden eating should not be a punishment
and your body should not need to be so
viciously manipulated like this these
are lessons that I personally am trying
to kind of learn and remember every
single day so I hope that you guys will
all join me on this journey as well so
guys as we close off I just want to
remind you that yes I am passionate here
about dismantling diet culture but what
I'm not interested in is dismantling
people's individual character so you
know yeah I want to make sure that if I
see misinformation on the Internet
I'm gonna call it out and I'm gonna do
it my way with science and SAS that's
what I always say but of course I want
to be sensitive that these are people's
lives and so when you're leaving
comments below I ask that you do so with
empathy and respect and kindness because
we're all just trying to move forward in
a positive light on this kind of food
and eating journey and I get it it's not
easy I was there too I was struggling
and so I'm really just trying to be
cognizant of that and and keeping the
comments section respectful on that note
please leave me a comment below if
there's a diet you want reviewed
something that you want clarified if
there's something you want fact checked
I want to know about it I read every
single comment don't forget to check out
the playlist right here for other what I
used a review
subscribe to the channel please share it
with your friends and I will see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]